time now for our seen and unseen segment
someone just ran behind the set s that's
it's orson welles this is fun it's live
TV that's right I think that what makes
it fun you know it's live I'm going to
do later I'm tap tonight the Orwellian
nightmare of socialized medicine exposed
by the plight of a dying child Kanye
West strikes again making liberal head
spin after tweeting support for Trump
and to put it all in perspective we're
joined by Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo Raymond the media coverage of the
first lady yesterday though focused on
her hat her hat Stephen Colbert kind of
captured it in this clip well got great
today the two men addressed the crowd
and there was an awkward moment Trump
goes for the kiss and oh saved by the
Hat
that is more than a hat that is a
defensive perimeter
their deal is either she gets to wear
the hat or Trump has to wear a cone the
cone of shame
there was actually coverage mainstream
coverage of this this idea and the
narrative is that the trumps are distant
that they're loveless that they don't
contact here's the bottom line like make
out and I guess but they're depriving
Melania of a really important moment
this woman yesterday fabulous Michelle
Obama when she was running the White
House or Laura Bush before her
they had teams of people I got hired
organized professional party planner to
do the same Roger screwed oh yeah there
are people snap can remember that well
but Melania Trump did this all on her
own she assembled a team of ten people
just her staff it's her staff she went
over the protocol the history well and
she has she chose the flowers the lights
the whole thing she should be given
credit for that not maligned for not
grabbing the hand when it was presented
she did hold his hand she did indeed let
him kiss her so this narrative
I'm tired of the scenario they cannot
give her one moment this was an elegant
wonderful beautiful presentation of
America to France and with a French
touch and the New Orleans doll jambalaya
you're weaving everybody I know I'm away
don't wait me you don't like me next
Alfie Evans this was this this is
another infuriating case optional health
service in Britain is preventing parents
from giving medical assistance to their
child tell us this is so heartbreaking
this little boy came in in December of
2016 he was brought to the hospital with
an infection he's been on a respirator
they said if you take the respirator out
he would die he wouldn't be able to
breathe on his own well it's been out
since Monday his parents fought to keep
the respirator if they don't want to pay
the money they don't want to spend the
money and I'm they say it's gonna and
the health service in Britain they look
at an actuarial table and they say not
human life does the cost exceed the
quality of life and in the case of this
little baby who has a degenerative brain
disease
they say he should be cut off no more
care parents are fighting they want him
to have care the father went to see the
Pope last week in desperation the Pope
not only blessed his effort he
interceded the Pope sent the head of the
Yaesu Bambino yaesu in Rome to Liverpool
England she is standing there the
doctors won't meet with her
there is a medical jet waiting to take
this child to Italy to get medical
treatment Paul won't release the Pope
wants to take the baby and and help the
baby and the in the in the National
Health Service won't let the Pope and
the in and give them Italian citizenship
too it gave them Italian citizens they
won't let him free now why I'll tell you
why because it's a shame it would be a
blight on the face of this national
health care which has become its own
religion to humanize to to to have a
citizen go elsewhere for medical care
they'd rather let the child die in the
hospital and that's the child is
suffering now because it's being died
and hydration as well or food well
they're giving it some hydration now but
let me tell you the networks in the
United States 28 minutes of coverage to
the royal birth none - Alfie Evans what
about is - no the Queen made some
statement of boil and William and Kate
as well but good news lots of prayer
services happening around the country in
New York tomorrow at noon at the UN also
Notre Dame today and other schools let's
pray for a miracle
pray for a miracle all right now this
has had the Twittersphere Twittersphere
going crazy I'm just glad isn't it when
it's not focused on me I'm not good day
but what is trending is Kanye West who I
I had a problem with when he took old
Taylor Swift's award out of her hand
member that old yeah right that was this
this here's a free right now he's he was
a pal at Trump's kinda he was around but
now he he issued this tweet today which
reads well he's of course the make
America great hat again but Benny came
out and said he loves trumpet and no mob
is going to dissuade him from that love
he is being attacked as you can imagine
he's must have watched are defending the
first series we have we've been doing on
the Ingraham angle because we've been
offending people's right to just have
different opinion I'm with two minds on
this I'll just make this yeah you're a
big hip-hop fan I'm a bit given right up
with Frank Sinatra like record sessions
but here's the idea I I'm not sure if
he's trying to promote his upcoming two
albums and his his line is a you know a
line of clothing or if this is truly a
cry for freedom of speech and might be
an opening in a community that has been
monolithic well sue didn't another hip
hopper come out yeah a chance the rapper
came out and said not all black people
have to be Democrats
this is no he's taking a chance taking a
chance yes there it is there's this
black people they had so we'll see where
this leads
if this hopefully this conversations why
can't they be white and white liberals
and white conservatives and black and
black conservative has to be monolithic
and one real it's it's diversity is more
fun that's prayers for baby Alfie
Raymond thank you some